[Musique]
deschamps
réponse
ce jardin n'est pas tout
l'avif
[Musique]
faire
c'est
il va nous
[Musique]
non
je n'ai
[Musique]
casini a presque c'est françois tu m'as
fait peur qu'est-ce que tu prépares
d'autres 2000
je suis en train de me préparer un
gloubi boulga à quoi un gloubi boulga
jeu de m'expliquer de quoi il s'agit
comment t'es tu ne sais pas ce que c'est
mais c'est mon dessert préféré je te
ferai goûter dès qu'il sera prêt
franchement j'ai jamais entendu parler
de ce dessert et casimir tuquoi qui me
plairait à moscou 8 tout le monde tout
le monde ne peut qu'adorer le cloud by
bull égal et qu'est ce que tu as mis
deux taules et bien qu'il y a d'abord du
chocolat en poudre en chocolat en poudre
et de la confiture de fraises confiture
de fraise
j'adore ça de la banane écrasée à
bananes écrasées ces travaux ne sait
très bien avec de la moutarde de de la
moutonne wii et de la saucisse de
toulouse de la banane écrasée du
chocolat en poudre de la confiture de
groseilles avec de la moutarde et de la
saucisse de toulouse
ah oui mais attention la saucisse de
toulouse est tiède mais n'est pas cuite
mais mais mais c'est épouvantable
casimir est vraiment sain ouais pourquoi
non face à ça pas l'air très
appétissants rare mais je ne comprends
pas tout le monde ne peut qu'adorer le
gloubiboulga est ce que vous pourriez
aimer le gloubiboulga ou non un écoute
casimir tu peux aimer le goût bulgare
cet endroit enfin c'est pas une raison
pour croire que tous ceux qui aiment ça
notons qu'un goût mais oui je crois que
tu ne connaissais pas apprécié ce qui
est bon c'est c'est tellement délicieux
le gloubiboulga tu vas voir les enfants
les voir bien bien sa drisse sauf à plat
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
gloubiboulga vous savez pas non mais je
vous le dire
c'est ce qu'a dans le bol de casimir
c'est un mélange de banane écrasée de
confiture de fraises de chocolat en
poudre avec de la moutarde et on est
hélas la saucisse de toulouse de la
saucisse de toulouse
attention la saucisse de toulouse tiède
mais cruel qui aident mais cru ça vous
tente
il est en danger de gloubiboulga nom
très longtemps débat durera casimir a
c'est vraiment désespérant de vivre dans
un univers où tous les gens personne n'a
le même goût que vous ce serait si
merveilleux de vivre dans un monde où
tout le monde aimerait le gloubiboulga
tu me donne encore un peu de temps lobby
boeing à casimir c'est vraiment nos
desserts préférés
ce qui est terrible c'est que tout le
monde dans l'île veut manger du
gloubiboulga et qu'il n'y a plus de
confiture de fraises nous de son fils de
travaux à parité et il ne me reste même
pas un peu dans l'oubli en garde pour
moi
arrêté à la mon pauvre casimir je me
demanderai toujours comment tu peux
aimer de la saucisse de toulouse tiède
mais cru avec de la banane écrasée de la
confiture de fraises et de la moutarde
main tu tu n'aime pas ça non pas du tout
à l'heure je comprends pas pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez tous voulu manger
monk lobby boulga tout à l'heure le
temps du tout casimir pas du tout ah bon
tu es du fleuret fille de 8 ans dormir à
et bien finalement j'aime mieux ça comme
ça je vais pouvoir manger mon globi
brugat tous aller sera là et je crois
qu'il vaut beaucoup mieux ne pas vivre
dans un monde où tous les genres et les
mêmes goûts avec propre françois regain
mombollet vide mon global gas a disparu
au jeu c'est lui à manger tout à l'heure
en dormant sans s'en rendre compte
obama ouah ouah ouah